anyone with two brain cells to rub
together has known for a long time that
blm is a racket
but even i did not appreciate just how
much of a racket it is
until blm's latest tax filings came out
we just learned that last year blm spent
millions and millions of dollars buying
expensive real estate in california i
guess that part we already knew we
called it by large mansions after all
that info came out now we have learned
that blm paid almost a million dollars
to co-founder patrice cullers's baby
daddy
damon turner turner received 970
thousand dollars to help produce live
events and to provide other creative
services the creative service in
question i suspect was co-creating
patrice colors as baby the group also
paid 840 000
to colors brother paul colors for
providing security services presumably
securing all of that money in his bank
account
this kind of political machine would
have made boss tweed blush the old
tammany hall democrat machine had
absolutely nothing on blm and we can
laugh at it
and we can even be outraged about it but
guess what
blm still has about 42 million dollars
in net assets on hand they've still got
an annual operating budget of four
million dollars and they've got no end
in sight to their donations
the democrat political machine is still
operating at a very high level the more
things change the more they stay the
same i'm michael knowles it's the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show i have two
favorite comments from yesterday it was
a total tie i could not pick just one
the first one is from the greco who says
the fact that michael has to explain why
harvesting spinal fluid from the young
to give to the elderly is a bad idea
shows just how far this world has fallen
i totally agree with that and then
second i thought this was a really
perceptive comment
brooke a crow says
i believe biden was supposed to say
alt-right mega-republicans
but now we have the best new gaffe
remember the other day joe biden said
the real problem in the politics is uh
hold on i want to say this right hold on
i want to i want to say this really
clearly
ultra mega republicans ultra maga and
you thought ultra maggot first of all
sounds kind of cool and second of all
you're telling me that the the democrat
campaign consultant spent six months
coming up with ultra maga ultra mega
what does that even mean no of course
not biden was not going off of a script
here he was trying to come up with it
even told you he said hold on i want to
get this right
he was obviously supposed to say
alt-right magger republicans that was a
phrase that the democrats had
workshopped for years that had been
testing very well so he was supposed to
say alt-right maggot republicans he
couldn't say it he said
ultra-magger republicans stupidly they
didn't want to admit that he made a
mistake and so now they're stuck with
ultra mega here we go baby we are ultra
mega
the democrat party is a machine
right now i'm reading a wonderful
biography of chester arthur
one of my favorite presidents he's not
the most well known he's mostly known
for his mutton chops but i'm i'm reading
about chester arthur you know in the
19th century both political parties
operated with machines patronage they'd
buy votes they'd
shake down the government workers to
work for the party and both parties did
it but the democrats really perfected it
the most famous political boss in
american history is boss tweed the most
famous machine in american political
history is tammany hall that was the
democrat
the
machine
is still operating
okay the machine
we like to flatter ourselves that all
the bad stuff that people did in the
past in politics we've totally cleaned
that up that doesn't exist anymore and
now everything's operating above board
and that's our democracy our sterling
stellar pristine democracy is operating
just as it should but that's not the
case
the democrats are still especially the
democrats republicans don't really have
a very well functioning machine right
now but the democrats do and that would
be blm and it's a shakedown racket and
they shake down the big corporations and
they raise 90 million dollars and they
pay off their cronies
and they pay off the stormtroopers on
the street and they pay off
just about everybody and it all operates
in a way that you have the entire
society working in concert to advance a
political message the media the news
media hollywood big tech the
universities
the the bureaucratic government the
elected government they're all working
together the corporations is it the way
they're working together
is because of a coordinated very
effective machine the sort of thing you
would have seen 150 years ago in
american politics you're still seeing it
today
it makes me think
in a slightly separate way but go with
me for a second makes me think of the
cia
makes me think of some of the
intelligence agencies
we today we all
look back and we remember all the shady
things that the intelligence agencies
have done they were invading foreign
countries toppling foreign governments
performing all sorts of experiments on
american citizens oh my mk ultra all
these crazy experiments gosh can you
believe they did that in the past i bet
they don't do any of that anymore though
right that's what people will say yeah
you know all of these institutions they
did a lot of shady dodgy things in the
past but they totally don't do any of
that anymore and it's all completely
cleaned up and different now
uh why
what would ever make you think that
that these institutions that have been
doing things for a very long time just
suddenly overnight stopped doing all the
bad things entirely
i don't buy that
and if we don't buy that with i don't
know an intelligence agency or something
like that why would we buy it with a
political party the more things change
the more they stay the same
so the way a machine works is you got a
carrot and you gotta stick
the carrot is when you grease the wheels
the carrot is when you pay people off
the carrot is when you give people
favors in patronage the stick is when
you punish people for for crossing your
machine and you're seeing that right now
the new democrat stick is accusing any
conservative
anyone who in any way calls out their
plans
of being a racist the worst thing that
you can possibly be called in america
today is a racist and so they wield this
very effectively and very loosely
one of the most important strategies for
the democrats
is mass migration
they have relied on mass migration
because statistically speaking new
immigrants and their kids and their
grandkids are much more likely to vote
for democrats than republicans and
republicans are making huge inroads with
hispanic voters that's true and
republicans
maybe in the future can make even more
inroads and republicans have long told
ourselves that latinos are
are republican they just don't know it
yet we say all these sorts of things
but the numbers just don't bear it out
okay even with the massive shift from
hispanic voters to the republican party
in recent years
it still
gives a huge advantage to democrats and
if you if you say that now if you say
that democrats are obviously using
immigration policy to
to
change the electorate change the
demographics of the country in a way
that they think will give them an
advantage you're called a racist awful
conspiracy theorist this is what joy
reid just said the other day they're
they're exploiting the shooting in
buffalo to attack tucker carlson in
particular because he's the most
prominent conservative television host
but really all of us everyone who has a
conservative podcast everyone who has a
conservative radio show everyone who's
an elected conservative or or just down
there at the grassroots level going to
your local republican meeting you are
being called a racist terrible evil
awful person who's responsible for a
shooting in buffalo because you're
calling out their strategy
no singular voice in right-wing media
has done more to elevate this racist
conspiracy theory than tucker
who even with a new head writer spends
night after prime time night injecting
the rot from the dregs of the internet
directly into the veins of republican
voters are tucker's writers sourcing his
show from 4chan
these are just questions
as the new york times analysis last
month found in more than 400 episodes
tuckums has amplified the idea that a
cabal of elites want to force
demographic change through immigration
that is replacement theory tucker's not
some deep thinker
he's clearly just channeling the gross
stuff his viewers could easily find
online than feeding it to republican
voters and republican politicians as
infotainment
and that feedback loop has terrifying
reach that murderous low life in buffalo
wouldn't even have to listen to tucker
he wouldn't have to watch him at all to
get it if they are essentially pulling
from the same source material
it's terrible disgusting evil false lies
propaganda the lowest of the low kind of
disinformation trash this idea that
elite people in our ruling class are
using immigration policy to change the
electorate so that they can get
political who would ever suggest such a
thing
it seems harder and harder to ignore
that the echoes of replacement theory
and other racially motivated views are
increasingly coming out into the open in
a few years we're going to be a majority
brown country white people will not be
the majority in the country anymore this
will be the first generation ever in
american history uh in which whites will
be a minority of the generation at some
point as of 2007
every year babies being born in this
country whites now are the minority in
2044
everyone is going to be a minority as
the demographics change as white people
become the minority in the country which
is coming demographics is destiny
demographics is destiny demographics is
destiny right the country is changing
i've been saying it here other people
been saying it here for years now even
before donald trump the demographics
is destiny the white population is
declining for the first time in history
in america while the number of
multi-racial americans
have more than doubled so we live in a
country where the demographics are
changing it's becoming less white
correct okay you'll be announcing that
we're calling the 38 electoral votes of
texas for the democratic nominee for
president it's changing it's going to
become a purple state and then a blue
state because of the demographics
because of the population growth this
goes on
for like another minute okay this goes
on and on and you see julian castro he's
saying look and it's going to totally
give us the win it's going to give us
texas which was one of the red estates
and it's because of people outside of
texas by which we mean mexico by which
we mean latin america and then joe
scarborough he says demographics is
destiny whoa cool it with the racist
great replacement theory there joe all
right i don't need this much racism in
my morning it's all the democrats who
have been spreading this
bragging about it for years those are
just the people on tv i could pull up
countless articles from left-wing think
tanks from left-wing newspapers not only
observing this fact but explaining how
this fact is due to mass migration which
is a very specific policy from very
specific lawmakers who are democrats for
a very specific purpose they're cheering
it on because they think that it will
give them an electoral advantage
and it's our fault because they told us
what they were doing they're doing a
thing to put themselves in power they
think permanently then they're telling
us that they're doing that thing and
then when we
repeat to them the thing that they just
told us they call us racist for
repeating it
doesn't make a lot of sense gets my
blood boiling that i'm being gaslit in
this way and when i want to relax you
know i gotta check out my all form right
now go to allform.com
knowles you know how much i love helix i
adore my helix mattress it's terrific
well helix has left the bedroom and
started making sofas they just launched
a new company called all form they are
already making the greatest sofas ever
what makes all form so cool well
it's the easiest way that you can
customize the sofa using premium
materials at a fraction of the cost of
traditional stores you pick the fabric
the color color of the legs the sofa
size the shape you make sure it's a
perfect fit for you and your home
they've got armchairs they've got love
seats it goes all the way up to an
eight-seat sectional and probably my
favorite part is let's say you're in a
small apartment right now but you know
you're gonna get a house at some point
you can grow your sofa with you you can
buy more seats later add them on really
easy really chic really really sleek
stuff right now they've got a forever
warranty that's right a forever warranty
so there's no risk whatsoever to find
your perfect sofa check out allform.com
knowles all form is offering 20 off all
orders for our listeners at allform.com
knowles
the
the stick there's the carrot which is
the the machine on the left pays you off
and they give you all sorts of patronage
then there's the stick which is they
call you a racist and they ostracize you
when they threaten you
and they can run run you out of your job
and run you out of your school and the
most basic way they do it is they
de-platform you if you say things that
contradict the prevailing orthodoxies of
the ruling class
you can be censored and de-platformed
that's what this fight on twitter is all
about
that's why elon musk is potentially
going to buy twitter
he's either going to buy twitter or
destroy twitter
because he says conservatives are not
being permitted to speak in the public
square
big tech is the new public square
self-government
only works when people can speak to one
another that's how we govern each other
so this is an existential threat to our
republic
this has hit me personally i have not
lost my twitter yet i have not lost my
youtube channel yet although
people have tried although there have
been some some strikes when uh on my
channel when i say things that are true
but if those true things contradict dr
fauci or contradict joe biden this
becomes a big problem on facebook also
but it's not any of those platforms that
i've lost
i have been kicked off of tick tock
i barely knew that i was on tick tock
i started a tick tock i would
occasionally post clips from my show to
tick tock
i did not use it because i am a grown
man
but sometimes i would have members of
the team post clips to tic toc because
that's where the youth are
i have not
accessed my tick tock in weeks and just
the other day a member of my team comes
running into my office says michael
you've been de-platformed on tick-tock
so why's that
why what have i done little old me me
whom everyone loved so i had not posted
anything there could not have been any
new offending content on there i didn't
receive any messages to why i was kicked
off i had previously posted videos
mocking
uh
dr fauci
not even mocking him personally just
mocking the lies that we have been told
the contradictions from the public
health establishment from joe biden and
then some weeks later poof i was kicked
off so you can't find me on tick tock
right now if you want to see me twerking
and jiggling and whatever else people
are doing on tik tok i'm sorry you're
going to have to tune into this show
you're not going to be able to get it
on tick tock i'm not i'm not so worried
that was not my main platform
although it it does matter actually i'm
sort of being glib about it now but it
does matter because
tick tock is where the young people are
and people spend a lot of time on tick
tock there was a study that showed that
on average twitter users spend about
three to six minutes a day on twitter
tick tock users who are who skew much
younger spend about 52 minutes a day on
tick tock so if you want to reach people
if you want a really powerful platform
you go to tick-tock the fact that one
can be censored and de-platformed off of
tick-tock
for any reason or no reason at all just
because they don't like the cut of your
jib or because you're contradicting the
ruling classes
propaganda of the week
that is very scary because that
reshapes the way that our political
order works if it reshapes the way we
can talk it reshapes the way our
political order works
this is why it's so important to
reassert some control over twitter we're
going to do it any way we can reassert
some control over google any way we can
reassert some control over facebook and
yes over tick tock
i think it would probably be better if
we in the political community if we
conservatives could get together
and go in and say no we're going to
assert our rights as americans and take
this power back from left-wing silicon
valley oligarchs
but we can take what we can get all
right if elon musk is the best way for
us to go in
and retake some of this political
control then that's the thing that we're
going to do
and maybe that means musk buys twitter
maybe that means
musk just destroys twitter maybe that
means musk never wanted to buy twitter
in the first place and this was all a
long troll to destroy the company which
increasingly it seems like it was elon
musk tweeted out the other day
quote 20
fake spam accounts
while four times what twitter claims
could be much higher
my offer was based on twitter's sec
filings being accurate yesterday
twitter's ceo publicly refused to show
proof of less than five percent bot
accounts
this deal cannot move forward until he
does
so do you see what's happened here
all the while we've been waiting all of
elon's cryptic messages he's quoting
poetry he's he's suggesting he'll maybe
join the board he won't join the board
he'll make a tender offer he doesn't
need to make the tinder up he's going to
go he and
what is he doing
they said if the board rejects your your
bid
elon what are you going to do he said
i've got a plan b i'm not going to tell
you what that is now well plan b or c or
d might not even be buying twitter it
might just be destroying twitter
because he's saying look i made my offer
of whatever it was 44 billion or
something
based on the idea that twitter has less
than five percent bot accounts
now does anyone believe that fewer than
five percent of the accounts on twitter
are bots and spam
i don't i'm just a regular twitter user
i think it's that number is way higher
if you use twitter surely you're going
to think that number is way higher elon
musk uses twitter a lot and he looked
into it enough to potentially buy
twitter you don't think that elon musk
maybe thought huh i think i think
twitter's official filings on the
spambot accounts they're probably a
little low no i think he probably
suspected they were
a little low
and so he goes in and he makes the offer
and then it goes all the way along here
and then he says wait a second
i'm looking over your
securities and exchange commission
filings here and you know it's looking
to me like you might have been dishonest
on some of your filings with the
government it's looking to me like you
might be committing some fraud against
your investors here
proves to me that fewer than five
percent of your accounts are bots and
spam and the ceo of twitter
for now the ceo of twitter prague
agrawal
said no we can't do that i wish we could
but there's no way we don't have any
access to show and elon just responded
with the little feces emoji
right underneath he said ah i'm pretty
sure you can but you don't want to
because what it's going to show is that
you guys are perpetrating a fraud
whatever elon does here whether he buys
it and opens up speech for conservatives
a little bit at least to some degree or
if he just destroys twitter either way
that will be a positive development
either way i cheer him on i don't know
which is funnier i actually can't decide
which is fine it's it's a longer joke if
elon runs twitter and gets to troll from
twitter
but
it is a spectacular magnificent joke if
he just does all of this
to destroy twitter for perpetrating a
fraud he would be destroying it not just
to
troll them and get get his kicks he
would be doing it with a purpose he'd be
he actually would be exposing a fraud he
actually would be improving speech in
the public square
that would it's it's as i frequently say
it is not enough to own the libs it's
good to own the lips i'm pro-owning the
lips but you one needs to own the lips
with purpose
you don't want to be frivolously owning
the libs
why is elon doing all of this is he
sincere what's his endgame
a lot of people have pointed out that
elon musk is a lib
he's a democrat he's an obama democrat
he voted for obama twice i believe
well now elon says
he's officially a republican he tweeted
out or i don't know if he tweeted this i
don't know how much he's using twitter
these days but he at least stated i have
voted overwhelmingly for democrats
historically
like i'm not sure i might never have
voted for a republican just to be clear
now this election i will
he posted a meme the other day of him
standing still
to the left of center you had the you
had the left of the political island the
right of the political aisle he was left
of center
and then
the leftists ran so far left and the
right didn't really move the right
actually moved a little bit to the left
and so now all of a sudden elon having
not moved at all is center right
that's what happened and so is ilan a
republican is he being sincere i suspect
he probably is i think there are a lot
of people
who would have called themselves
liberals or leftists even or center-left
who now are firmly on the right because
they hold such radical positions as
don't chop off little kids genitals such
radical positions as don't kill little
babies one minute before they're born
such radical positions as hey maybe a
handful of woke bazillionaires shouldn't
completely dominate our political
discourse
and the establishment is trying
desperately to counter that narrative so
sunny hostin on the view insists no no
elon you're wrong no no most americans
you're wrong actually it's the
republicans who have moved much further
to the right they are playing to the
base i mean if you look at all the
studies the republican party has moved
further to the right than democrats have
to the left there's a pew research
center analysis that finds that on
average democrats and republicans are
farther apart ideologically today than
at any time in the past 50 years and
that ideological divide breaks down to
the republican party being an extremist
party and the democratic party actually
as you just mentioned sarah moving more
to the center but isn't the problem that
is the primaries because you can't get
through these primaries unless you are
extreme especially right now in the
republican party
that claim that sunny hostin just made
is so ridiculous it almost isn't worth
responding to i will respond to it
because it's going to be a common
refrain in this election
on what issue had the democrats moved to
the center
on what issue
on abortion no they went from safe legal
and rare to abortion on demand without
apology up to the moment of birth and
maybe afterward on immigration no they
went from we've got to keep illegal
aliens out of our country too we need
completely open borders and 3 million
migrants coming in per year 2 million of
whom are illegal on what on sexual
issues no we went from maybe teach sex
ed in high schools to we need to trans
the kindergarteners i don't think so on
on what issue on what issue have they
become
on free speech no they went from let's
tolerate free speech to let's censor all
the conservatives and what they've moved
radically left on all of the issues what
about the republicans where have they
moved right on abortion they're
basically the same maybe they've moved a
little bit more pro-life on abortion but
basically they're the same on guns no
they're pretty much the same on guns on
taxes if anything they've moved to the
center on on taxes and economic issues
on
the social issues on marriage oh my gosh
they they many republicans have just
bought a complete radical redefinition
of marriage given to them by the radical
left i don't think there on on what
issue on
if the republicans have moved at all and
i suppose they have they've moved
to the center
and i'm this is not just well the
leftists say that it's the other guys
who moved and it's the conservatives say
it's the other guy no you just look at
the issue by issue tell me where i went
wrong
i don't think i've said anything wrong
i'm giving specific examples i can prove
my argument sunny hostin is just
spouting platitudes because her party
has moved radically to the left
now
we have
a phenomenal new system in place
such that we can talk to one another
not just where you write into me in the
mail bag i like that too but where you
can
submit your voice mail bag how do you do
it it's on
the website you go to the daily wire
website
you record your
the voicemail bag just on your phone you
record it you know just a little phone
recording app you scroll down on the
website you click on the michael knowles
show right there on the page
scroll on down you click mail bag okay
great
and then ordinarily you can just there
you go you pop up that
you pop up that
email okay then you add your audio file
boom mp3 boom send and then i get to
hear from you on the show so do that
we're gonna be doing that on friday it's
gonna be a lot of fun also we have
released a three-part docu-series called
fouchy unmasked you remember that hosted
by yours truly exposing
the great exalted most powerful
politician in the country dr anthony
fauci
you've got to go check out that film
take a look at the trailer
he's the highest paid employee in our
federal government
and beginning in the spring of 2020 dr
fauci began to set national policy that
affected the way that 330 million
americans lived their lives for goodness
sakes i'm telling you wear a mask keep
social distancing there's nothing
political about that but who is anthony
fauci people who have conspiracy
theories those are people that don't
particularly care for me in this short
series
we will do what the establishment media
have refused to do we will give you an
unvarnished look at the career of the
most powerful politician in america
dr anthony fountain don't you think it's
time that you step down and let someone
else who has a more effective message
actually no
[Music]
so we've got the three-part series fauci
unmasked we've got another documentary
that i'm hosting that would be the
legacy of roe choosing death the legacy
of roe that's also available now join
our fearless fight for the truth by
becoming a member today dailywire.com
subscribe and watch fouchy unmasked and
watch choosing death the legacy of row
new members can use code knowles k w lis
for 20 off your membership you're
getting so much content this is an
extremely good deal and you get 20 off
with code knowles we'll be right back
with a lot more
it's the conservatives who have moved
radically to the right right it's not
that the left has moved radically to the
left it's the the right wing has moved
radically to the right right like
like for instance right now
if you object to
little kids little boys being told that
they're little girls and dressed up like
little girls and being encouraged to
mutilate themselves
if you oppose that in any way that makes
you a far-right extremist right there's
a mother
who should probably be arrested
certainly have her children taken from
her who posted a video to tic toc
uh dressing up her little boy in dresses
and encouraging him to pretend to be a
girl
you love it
and you want it and you picked it out
but you don't have to but you don't want
it for school can you tell me why
because last time i wore a dress to
school everybody called me a girl what
makes a shirt for a boy or a girl
nothing
so do you want this you picked it out
i do love it you want to wear it all the
time at home but not at school right
yeah tell me about that i don't want to
get made fun of and that's what they
always do when i wear pink
stuff do you think bright pretty colors
and dresses and sequins and jewels and
golds all the things that you always
want to wear
do you think that's your innermost you
it is well how are you going to be your
innermost you when we live in a place
that people think
clothing belongs to particular gender
so the decision to dress up like a
little girl that was obviously just this
little boy's personal decision right
he's not being coached and he's not
being coached right before our very eyes
hey you you love wearing sequins and
dresses right that's what you really
want to do right you want to do that
thing
uh yeah okay
yeah and you but why won't you wear the
dresses to school uh because the kids
call me a girl when i do that because
i'm dressing up like a girl and that's
weird
uh yeah and it's that's that's bad that
that happens right and you do you tell
me how much you want it
tell me how much you totally wanted and
it's not just me a sick
very sick twisted pervert mother
abusing her child and
and grooming that's what that's what the
grooming is right when we use the phrase
grooming and groomers
people think it has only this very
narrow application
to
adults who are trying to have sex with
children
but it has a much broader application
than that it is adults who are
inculcating a sexual sense a sexual
desire a sexual identity a sexual
orientation in little kids
this is why we called the teachers
groomers when they were having private
sexual conversations with kids that they
didn't want their parents to hear about
it's not just because the teachers
wanted to have sex with the students
maybe they do maybe some of them do
but it's because it's still extremely
creepy
and psychologically damaging
and accomplishing much of the same
damage
if you're just
cultivating a disordered sexual identity
in a kid like when this mother
shamelessly abusively puts her kid on
tick tock without saying we censored his
face she didn't censor his face that was
i when i saw this video going around the
internet i said okay i want to use this
video
we have to talk about this but don't you
dare put this kid's face you know you
our editors have to censor that because
if his parents are not going to look out
for him at least at least we will to to
the extent that we're exposing what his
parents are doing
and she's and she's just there with that
phone okay and you like this and you
want to wear the dresses and you want to
live out whatever sick fantasies i've
got in my head right
says the mother
and if you oppose that you're the
radical she's not the radical because
the left has moved to the center
according to sonny hostin
you're the radical
if you think it's wrong to do that to
little boys
you're the radical if you if you believe
that
babies uh before the moment of birth
should not be killed that that it's
wrong to kill ba there was a a
pro-abortion rally at the arizona state
capitol
two sides here you've got the pro-life
side quietly demonstrating praying being
polite being normal and you've got the
pro-abortion side screaming until
they're blue in the face which side
seems more radical
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
that means your mom stuck and killed her
your upper hue and tried to get rid of
you but she failed
so if you just listened to that clip you
you get probably 80
of
what was going on there and if you watch
that you get the whole thing you
probably get more you probably get about
150 of
of the distinction between pro-abortion
side and the pro-life side here
on the pro-life side you get
really the one person you can see is
this looking kid wearing a usa hat say
you know like a maga type hat saying you
know
like smiling and looking normal and just
sort of like what what do you mean he
kind of reminds me of that kid who was
wearing the maga hat in washington dc
nick sandman when all the crazy
screaming leftists are banging drums in
his face and yelling he's just there
kind of
vaguely smiling bemused
that's what that kid the pro-life kid
was doing and then the pro-abortion side
screaming shrieking saying all sorts of
profanity hideous vile things with crazy
hairdos and
not looking like not looking like
they've got their lives in order okay
not looking like these are the most
grounded people on earth
but we're the radicals right
we're the crazy extremists
the kid in the hat
smiling
pro-america usa maga
just normal he's the crazy extremist and
the shriek the people shrieking about
coat hangers and how pro-lifers should
be aborted and with all sorts of
physical eccentric uh you know clothing
and tattoos and piercings and hair
colors they're the normal ones they're
the ones who they've actually moved to
the center
according to sonny hawston
who are the extremists it's not just
these crazies on the street i am not
just strawmenting this we are talking
all the way up to the most elite levels
of the democratic party right now
katanji jackson is
about to become the new new judge on the
supreme court
catanji jackson has not has not really
played a uh
role in the court yet obviously but she
was confirmed she's set to replace
justice breyer after the current term
ends
katanji was interviewed by the
washington post and asked what she
thought about the protests outside of
the homes of the judges
after the leak of of the potential
opinion in dobbs versus jackson women's
health
this is a layup this was an easy
question
well it's two questions one do you
condemn the leak two do you condem
protests outside of the homes of the
federal judges
which is in violation of federal law
and katanji says you know i just can't
comment on that
you know i just i just don't know i
don't know
specifically she said if uh
leaking the draft opinion was a good
thing or a bad thing she said i can't
answer that
every judge who's given an opinion on
this so far
has answered that and said this is
terrible it's eroded the trust of the
court this is a really awful thing she
says yeah i can't answer that
i don't know
yeah maybe uh maybe brett kavanaugh is
going to f around and find out i don't
know
yeah
there are people screaming and
threatening his family and yelling
outside in the middle of the night while
his little children try to fall asleep
yeah i don't know i can't answer if
that's good or bad
i don't know find out
i don't i don't have any comment she
says on the protests outside of the
homes i can't answer whether it's good
or bad that a clerk destroyed the trust
of the court and leaked the opinion
early and caused the protests in the
first place
before this woman was confirmed
i put on my nostradamus hat took out my
crystal ball and i said this woman would
be the most radical person in the
history of the supreme court as i just
looked at her record
i looked at her intellectual pedigree
and her her political pedigree
and i looked at
the the way she was conducting herself
during the hearings she she wouldn't
even say what a woman was she laughed at
the suggestion that she could define
what a woman is
so haha i'm not a biologist i said we
haven't seen this kind of radicalism
ruth bader ginsburg
elena kagan even sonia sotomayor have
nothing on this chick
and what do we see
what do we see she says oh yeah well
you're going to protest outside the
homes i don't know well you want you
want me to condemn that i can't i can't
condemn that
you're gonna leak the opinion i can't
condemn that
speaking of the court there was a big
win at the supreme court yesterday for
conservatives and it's not getting a ton
of play and it actually comes from ted
cruz my intrepid co-host on verdict on
the verdict podcast
senator cruz
brought a case to the supreme court i
think it's called cruz versus fec
so his name is right there in the case
and he brought this case because john
mccain had a very stupid campaign
finance law
and the stupid campaign finance law
proposed to set limits on the way that
big money enters into politics that was
theoretically the idea that was at least
what the marketing team said about it
but that's not really what it did most
of what the mccain feingold campaign
finance rules did was just to protect
incumbents this is why the incumbents
voted for it is because it protected
them from challenges to to people going
out and running and draining the swamp
so it was a really swampy piece of
legislation and
lots of it has already been struck down
by the courts and even at the time that
george w bush signed it into law
bush said yeah i don't really know if
this is constitutional or not but
whatever the courts can decide which was
an abdication of his duty as well the
president of the united states has a
responsibility to defend the
constitution too so i thought that was
weak stuff from george w bush as well
well now it's been struck down
specifically what was struck down here
was a provision that would allow
political candidates running for office
to reimburse themselves for money that
they had lent to their campaign
so when you run for office especially if
you're a challenger candidate no one
knows you you don't have any name
recognition
a way to even get yourself in the
running is to donate money to your own
campaign
so we're not talking about
gazillionaires here gazillionaires don't
need to pay themselves back if you've
got 50 million dollars and you loan your
campaign half a million bucks a million
bucks or 10 million bucks you don't care
if you ever get that money back it can
go to the government and who it doesn't
matter and we're not talking about
people who are who don't have any money
we're not talking about because they
wouldn't be able to loan themselves
money in the first place we're talking
about doctors we're talking about
lawyers we're talking about
professionals who who do well who have
money who could make a big loan to them
let's say they could loan their campaign
i don't know three hundred thousand
dollars
four hundred thousand dollars
according to the mccain rules you can
only pay yourself back 250.
and so it was basically just a way to
cap challengers at what they were even
able to donate to their own campaign so
it would be harder for them to win uh
that was just struck down
this was the reason i really like this
case
is because
it's
it's not just a left versus right or
republican versus democrat this case
really was a drain the swamp kind of
case this this one this will hurt
political corruption in both parties it
gets back to that machine politics we
were talking about at the very top of
the show this is a way to uh
well not to get money out of politics
because you you can't get money out of
politics that's not possible and usually
like mccain feingold usually the laws
that purport to get money out of
politics actually
preserve the money in politics actually
because big politics always attracts big
money all that's going to happen is when
you pass laws about money in politics
the money just goes elsewhere the money
just kind of hides itself or the money
is
is
really only accessible to a certain
protected political class
like the gazillionaires who don't need
to pay themselves back like the
incumbents who have huge war chests and
not the challengers so this was a big
win good win for conservatives
we're also now looking at the
pennsylvania senate race which is
extraordinarily close there were i told
you yesterday on the show the
pennsylvania senate race
was going to
give you a hint of what the future of
the republican party looked like
there were three top candidates dr oz
the
daytime tv talk show host
who seemed like a pretty liberal
candidate actually and was very recently
attacking pro-life laws around the
country from the gop
and has done shows promoting
transgenderism and kids and all sorts of
madness
you had david mccormick who seemed like
kind of a business republican
not you know not the most rock stalwart
conservative but not a total squish
either but you know just kind of a
centrist moderate uh business republican
and then kathy barnett who was a
political commentator she didn't have a
ton of money uh we didn't know a ton
about her she was probably the newest to
the political scene
at least at the national level and she
was the most conservative in terms of
her positions
we still don't have an exact answer on
on who won the race it was very very
close kathy barnett was a distant third
so the the rock rubbed conservative in
the race really fell down she'd surged
in the polls then she fell down
mccormick
as election night was concluding
mccormick was leading dr oz was in
second place but we're talking about by
tenths of a percentage point so knowing
the way that they count the votes in
pennsylvania it seems unlikely that
they're they're going to instantly
come out with an answer
that that battle in pennsylvania though
we'll also show you a little bit more
about where the party is ted cruz
endorsed david mccormick
donald trump endorsed dr oz
some
more right-wing conservative groups seem
to go from between oz and and mccormick
seemed to go for mccormick
sean hannity went for dr oz but a lot of
the conservative base really doesn't
like dr oz so you're seeing trump has a
decent record right now on the
endorsements in ohio for instance
cruz endorsed josh mandel donald trump
endorsed jd vance jd vance one so what's
going to happen in pennsylvania you're
what you are seeing right now
in these races even if you don't really
care about the republican primaries and
even if you don't really care about 2022
what you are seeing play out is a shadow
campaign for 2024 whose endorsements
matter who is going to have the right
favors going in whereas we haven't even
talked about the endorsements that ron
desantis has made we haven't even talked
about the endorsements that other
potential that mike pompeo has made that
nikki haley has made that other
presidential candidates are making that
is part of the race that's playing out
right now
now a huge issue in pennsylvania is
energy energy is a really big issue
and you know that the two parties have
totally different views on energy right
now
what we are led to believe you want to
talk about grift you want to talk about
machine politics you want to talk about
disingenuous political rhetoric what we
are told is
if you support
fossil fuels
if you support
if you if you in any way oppose
solar
wind green energy renewable electric
cars if you oppose that in any way you
are destroying the earth you're going to
kill all of mankind within
well it used to be
nine years now it's what it's probably
seven or eight years at this point
it's the same kind of argument you see
in in buffalo they'll say if you in any
way call out democrats immigration
strategy then you're responsible for a
massacre in buffalo if you in any way
oppose democrats radical energy reforms
you're responsible for the destruction
of the earth john kerry the white house
climate czar
has come out and said that the
united states needs to transition to
electric cars transition meaning you
lose your current car and you have to
get an electric car
we need to transition at 20 times the
current rate
this year we have to implement those
promises and what it means is we have to
decarbonize
uh the power sector five times faster
than we are right now
we have to
deploy renewables
five times faster than we are right now
uh we have to
uh transition to electric vehicles about
20 times faster than we are now and we
have to fully transition to a resilient
net zero economy faster
we have to do must transit you all need
to go buy teslas
and you have to and if you can't afford
if you're a pauper and you can't afford
the model x for 96 000
well at least you dirty peasants can get
the model s can't you isn't that one's
only about 45 000
what that's chump change so you have to
buy your tesla and uh and you have to
put solar panels on your roofs and you
have to
do if you don't do all of this and buy
from our companies then the world will
end
why are they doing this
why are they doing this are
are the libs promoting
this particular segment of the energy
industry
out of the goodness of their heart or
because they genuinely believe the world
is going to end in seven years or
because they haven't noticed that all
the predictions they've made on the
climate and the environment for the last
50 years haven't happened
and they keep changing the predictions
radically sometimes to the opposite of
the predictions they had just previously
made or do you think it's because of
that
or do you think it's because
the republicans own oil and gas and the
democrats own electric
with a little bit of an exception of
elon musk who used to be a democrat
who's now seems to be transitioning to a
republican everyone's transitioning
these days
what do you think it is i think call me
a cynic call me jaded i think it might
have a little bit more to do with the
latter i don't think the democrats
really care all that much about the
climate i don't think they're really
worried about the world ending in 10
years most of them the elite democrats i
think
i think it's a grift i think it's i
think it's a regular old hustle just
like all the rest of their politics and
i think that they've got a crooked
relationship with the green energy
companies you saw this with the the
scandal during the obama administration
there's a major environmental company uh
scandal that the name of the company now
escapes me
oh it's going to drive me crazy i'll
google it right after the show it was
such a
one of the it's hard because there were
so many scandals during obama but it was
a it was a bigger one it was a green
energy company where the federal
government was funneling a ton of money
into it and it wasn't doing anything it
was just a grift and it was a payoff and
it was patronage for loyal democrats and
you're seeing this throughout that whole
sector
the
cleanest energy you could possibly have
would be nuclear energy that would be
the best way to reduce carbon it would
be extremely efficient the democrats
don't endorse that because that's not
part of the democratic grift it's not
part of the machine so they don't they
don't get behind that fossil fuels for
that matter are extraordinarily abundant
there are ways to use them that are
cleaner and cleaner every single day
there are ways to capture carbon if
that's really something that you want to
do in your politics if you're really so
afraid of of any kind of warming
so there are ways to do that but they
don't like it
because fossil fuels are for the
republicans
if you want to understand what political
debates
are really about at the level of policy
you are going to have a much
clearer understanding if you first look
to the money
than if you first look to the philosophy
maybe there are some philosophical
considerations too but if you want to
understand blm how are you going to
understand it are you going to
understand it simply by reading kimber
like crenshaw and derrick bell and
critical race theory and
or are you going to understand it by
looking at where the money's going and
you're looking at patrice culler's
paying off her baby daddy and you're
looking at patrice colors paying off her
brother and you're looking at the
corporations paying off blm and you're
looking at the democrat politicians
hustling and raising money to bail out
the blm criminal what do you think is
going to
make more sense what do you think is a
greater motivator for these politicians
there's one last story speaking of
fossils that i have to get to i've been
meaning to get to it for a few days
huge discovery in china
china has discovered a 66 million year
old dinosaur embryo fossil oh my
goodness may 8th 2022 just happened just
a week or so ago
scientists from the fujian science and
technology museum and the china
university of geosciences revealed the
discovery
in a study published in the journal bmc
ecology and evolution
this new dinosaur embryo fossil
comes from the zhengxi province at least
two of the eggs contain identifiable
hydrosauroid
embryos i don't know if i'm pronouncing
that correct hydroceroid i don't know
described here for the first time and my
only question for them is
how do you know
how do i guess i have two questions one
how do you know what do you mean it's a
little baby hydrosteroid
i thought it was just a clump of cells
i
i have been reliably informed by the
libs that until the moment of birth
life forms are just their little
meaningless stupid clumps of cells so my
first question is how do you know what
it is how can you identify 66 million
years old you can't even identify a
human baby that was conceived two months
ago and then my second question is well
who cares
who cares it's just it's just a
meaningless pointless clump of cells
that can just be thrown in the trash
so why does that matter
hold on you're telling me that a 66
million year old clump of cells from a
dead lizard
is more important than
a human baby a little human baby
that you're also calling a meaningless
clump of cells that doesn't see i think
i think they're kind of giving away the
game a little bit folks i think the
logic is falling apart now
whether the the extremely effective
political machine will fall apart as
easily as their logic that is another
matter i'm michael knowles the michael
knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
hey there this is john bickley daily
wire editor-in-chief and co-host of
morning wire on today's episode
democrats push controversial new
domestic terrorism laws following the
buffalo mass shooting the house
intelligence committee holds a public
hearing on ufos
and a key trial stemming from the durham
investigation begins
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire